I had forgotten how much I enjoyed
spinning with moonblaze style heads
until I got these one of my favorite
things to do is just hand my phone to
somebody and have them like use it to
control what Graphics are coming up on
these but these have rapidly become kind
of my secret weapon hey friends so it's
been a couple years since I last checked
in and told you all what POI are in
Common Rotation in my household so I
thought I would do a little update you
know just in time for the holidays 2022
and see if there's anything in here that
y'all might be interested in gifting to
the flow artist of choice in your lives
Drex here from drexfactor Koi sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today well I'm going to show you all
of the props and see if they can benefit
your bodies and Brands as much as
they've benefited mine but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Terra light toys spin balls and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinsky and
Becca becklinen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission
so I spend POI for a living and the
question does come up relatively often
what exactly do I like to spend with and
the answer is several different things
so I have arranged a little bit of a
spread here my plan is to take us
through from daytime spending to led to
Fire and Company by company to kind of
give you a rough idea of what I like to
spin with so let's get started and the
first set of poi that I'm going to tell
you about are these right here from uh
potiki POI they are a new zealand-based
company that is run by a young Maori
woman I haven't had a lot of chance to
use these just yet but it is one of my
big New Year's resolutions to learn more
Maori style POI and I'm excited to have
these to work with you should check this
company out they are po Tiki POI
p-o-t-i-k-i-poi.co.nz you can buy from
their online shop and get a set of these
for yourself
and hopefully we can start bringing back
some of that uh some of that Maori style
to what we do yeah all right so moving
on we have the this that's a POI that I
most often use for my video tutorials
these are the contact POI that I got
from uh Lantern Smith the company
founded by nine square Theory out tour
Charlie Cushing I love the fact that you
can adjust the weight really easily uh
you know the weight is
locked inside of these little cartridges
right here inside the heads you can
really easily swap out the handles and
the tethers if you want to and of course
the cavities that these cartridges fit
inside of are just the right size to fit
in uh capsule lights from flow toys and
if you have seen pretty much any
tutorial that I have created in the past
couple years you have definitely seen
these POI these are without a doubt my
favorites over at lanternsmith.com you
can use the promo code
directs factor with a zero instead of an
O to get a discount on a set of these at
checkout
um seriously best contact point out
there by far Lantern Smith check them
out all right so next up we have sock
POI from sockboy this is a Russian based
company that is run by uh Katya
stakonova AKA One Day spin on Instagram
but these have rapidly become kind of my
secret weapon
um for one thing they're super soft I
like have absolutely no fear of trying
out new tricks with these at all they
also squish down really well and of
course they're super visible like
especially in daytime regardless of what
lighting I'm using these just tend to
stand out like you wouldn't believe
these are kind of always the thing that
I put in my bag these are my default set
of poi to take out with me during the
day that kind of snuck up on me but um I
gotta say like the way that they handle
has really grown on me and I'm a fan now
so sock POI you can get a set of these
over at I believe it is
sockpoi.store and tell Katya that I sent
you because she's good people and
deserves our support and her POI are
really rad all right next up let's get
into some Led POI here so first pair I'm
going to show you are my pod POI with uh
FPC tethers thicker rope has definitely
kind of just become the industry
standard over the course of the past
couple years and once I started
practicing with them regularly all of a
sudden like you know the the tethers
really started growing on me you know
pod POI are always a good choice for any
uh skill level so you know whether it's
beginner uh intermediate or Advanced
tricks I'm trying out new things or I'm
working back through some things that
I've known for years these are always a
good fit if I'm going out after dark
these are now the set that I take with
me these are what go into uh my bag
they're very low profile they're easy to
fit in they're nice and Squishy you know
I can set up a video camera I'll be able
to see them nice and clear even in the
dark so yeah I'm a fan
um yeah flow toys well done on these all
right so let's check out another set
from flow toys which I don't use these
as often anymore simply because
um I'm doing more videos with the Pod
POI but I still have these spin 90 or
excuse me spin nine uh Vision POI they
do show patterns when you spin them but
you can't program necessarily with those
items are going to be like you can't
stick a message or a logo in there that
said they do produce some really
interesting images I still pick these up
from time to time they're not in
frequent Rotation by any means but one
thing I do like about them is just like
if if I want to get up and you know just
horse around with some patterns these
are great
um you know they make flowers look much
cooler they make body tracers and weaves
look really interesting yeah I would I
would definitely give these a look-see
if you're interested in trying out some
of the uh more top shelf stuff that uh
that flowtoys offers and of course with
both the Pod POI and the spend night
vision POI I have a promo code over at
flow toys you can use the promo code
drexfactor 2022 that is Drex factor with
a three instead of an e at checkout that
gets you a discount on your order also
helps out the channel flowtoys thanks so
much for working with me like that and
um yeah I'm sure that y'all will get a
lot out of these too all right so next
up let's start diving into some other
LED stuff so um
when I'm practicing by myself close to
my house most often I'm using LED
contact POI these are my defaults these
are what I use for all of my sponsored
uh LED videos for Ultra POI these of
course are their orb POI Pros some of
the things that they updated in these
that I think are fantastic the tethers
are sweet also the heads are so much
brighter than the first generation it
comes with the expense of battery life
but at the same time like you can see
these clutch these heads excuse me
pretty clearly at night and especially
when I'm doing flow videos that's proven
to be really really helpful in producing
dance videos at like Twilight or so
sometimes these will even be my contact
POI when I'm running around during the
day depending upon how much room I have
in my bag but yeah these are super solid
these are these are kind of like my
default POI to reach for depending upon
what I'm working on so um they're pretty
rad and next up we have
a new Contender so these are the Helix
POI pros from Ultra POI now in the past
year I've been trying to work a lot more
with glow stringing style POI
um this hasn't been as consistent a
thing as I would have liked these are
really fantastic for doing very very
lightweight and glow streaming types of
moves as you can see I have modified
them to remove as much Hardware as
possible I'm literally just taking the
tethers straight around through the
heads if you like me are interested in
dipping your toes into the glow
streaming world I highly recommend
and of course I got a promo code with
ultra POI so both the orb POI pros and
the Helix POI Pros you can get them over
at ultrapoi.com you can use my promo
code drexfactor with a zero instead of
an O at checkout helps out the channel
and it gets you a discount and also uh
Ultra POI just a big thank you because
they were the first company to sponsor
me doing flow videos and
um that meant a lot to me all right so
next up we're going to get into the
realm of programmable POI and I have two
options for programmable POI all right
so first up we have Bubble POI from
ignis now we don't use these as much as
I used to I tend to only use these when
I go out on one of the big group bike
rides through DC just as like kind of a
fun treat for the other people on those
bike rides but where they Excel not only
in the fact that they're programmable
but also the smartphone app that they
have one of my favorite things to do
when I'm out on those bike rides is just
hand my phone to somebody and have them
like use it to control what Graphics are
coming up on these usually people really
really like this and of course just even
Beyond controlling the uh the images
that pop up on these the app is just
fantastic as like a fitness tracker
there's so much you can do with it
definitely the best smartphone app I've
found for flow Arts thus far so uh yeah
these are still in my rotation here you
can get these over at I believe it is
ignispixel.com and I have a promo code
with these folks too you can use
drexfactor over there to get a discount
on a set of these
um really fun as far as I know still the
only sets of programmable uh LED contact
POI out there alright so next up we have
the visual POI 4.0 minis from pyrotera
Lite toys these are my gigging POI of
choice so just straight up I've used
many many sets of programmable POI over
the years and these are just without a
doubt the most user friendly and the
desktop program whether it be on Windows
or on OS X
um it's definitely the most intuitive
and user-friendly version of uh software
to program programmable Ploy that I've
seen yeah these are just a super
professional and uh really really
awesome product so these these are my
defaults you'll pull them out of my cold
dead hands whether I'm gigging or not
and once again I have a promo code for
these I believe it is Drex light toys
Factor 2021 uh if I get that wrong I'll
correct the text down below but
um yeah these are just without a doubt
the most polished and professional sets
of programmable LED POI that I have ever
used all right now let's start getting
into some fire POI here shall we all
right so first up let's take a look at
these these of course well you can't see
them because I've got the heads stuck
inside of these bags here they're very
very and they're not going to look
like much on camera anyway but these are
monkey fist heads these are a set of poi
from crispy clowns I got these years ago
they're also modified I went ahead and
stuck Ultra POI Ultra knob Pros on them
these were my default fire POI for kind
of a long time they have the kind of
interesting little cages in them that
are packed with an absorbent material so
the burn times on these are fantastic
and have stayed relatively consistent
over the years mainly what I use these
for is just burns that I know I need to
have a really consistent burn time for
so um yeah they still wind up in
rotation on occasion but they're
definitely not my primary Fire Point
anymore so what are my primary fire POI
now I'm so glad you asked it would be
this sets from fire Mecca yeah so we got
moonblaze heads here as well as these
technology tethers that have the steel
safety cable running through them as you
can see they're slightly stiffer than
the technora
tethers from crispy clowns but it
doesn't make that big a difference in my
spinning style they have the original uh
Ultra knob LED handles on them so I like
these honestly because the Flames a
little bit smaller than there with
monkey Fists so I feel safer doing more
dance based stuff earlier in a burn I
feel safer taking a few more chances
there
also too just like the peace of mind I
get from spinning with the uh with the
the safety cables inside is fantastic I
had forgotten how much I enjoyed
spinning with moon Blaze style heads
until I got these and most important of
all like as they were prototyping these
uh I emailed back and forth with uh
Connor the guy who runs fire Mecca he
was really responsive to all of my
feedback
and the product that he produced I think
really has uh has has benefited as a
result and even better they are working
with me now the first fire POI company
to offer me a discount code so over at
firemeka.com you can go use the promo
code drexfactor at checkout to get
yourself a discount on a set of these
and course it helps out the channel so
everybody wins cool so what sets a POI
are you using in regular rotation these
days do you agree with my assessments of
these do you have your own favorites
please leave me a comment and let me
know I'd love to hear
[Music]
if you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like share comment
and subscribe to help other people find
it to help keep the conversation going
and of course to help my channel grow
thanks in advance so this video would
not be possible we're not for the kind
support of all of these lovely people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
nice people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very very
generous support and if you out there
are watching this video and you'd like
to support my work you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI and signing up you can do
that at the link down in the description
or the card that just popped up if you
are watching on YouTube there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and be helping me out in my
mission so go check that out please and
thank you if you'd like to check out my
reviews of any number of different flow
Arts products I will go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of them
down in the description as well as up on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video based upon
your past viewing habits so maybe give
that a look as well thanks so much for
watching have yourselves a good one I
hope you find the POI that worked for
you and I will see you with the new
video real soon
thanks so much and take care peace